c'est notre chambre et dans cette chambre
il y a deux quatre six lits certaines chambres
ont huit je pense que nous avons l'une des
plus petites chambres et c'est mon pod mon
nom ici et c'est comme ça mon pod donc
j'ai comme une tonne de comme mon  des trucs comme
derrière ici j'ai des sacs et des trucs de
vêtements et des trucs comme ça à peu près
toute ma vie est dans ce pod oh c'est un
petit pod confortable et ouais j'en suis
content comme je suis reconnaissant tu vois ce que
je veux dire j'aime  que j'ai trouvé cet
endroit et que j'apprécie tous les jours
[Musique]
Oh, mettez un peu d'endo petit prévôt Zelezny
Mishima représente Goleta Californie la
ba la Chris DeRose Motel colonne
encouragement femmes portent un ampli basse un
niveau personnel de los angeles san diego
san francisco de la précision à  t.rosile
vu operations American economy country
say pessimal personal californee salsa
m'a attrapé personnellement stérile
règles donc c'est mon
pod ici je partage une chambre avec neuf
autres gars donc je suis l'un des dix dans cette
pièce ici donc c'est un deux trois
quatre cinq six sept huit neuf dix à
vivre dans un espace restreint comme celui-ci le
principal  le truc c'est de compartimenter et que
tout ait une
place  pod je
n'avais pas de maison pendant les cinq premiers
jours que j'étais ici, alors j'ai juste dormi dans
ma voiture et je pense que beaucoup de gens font
ça, je pense que beaucoup de gens déménagent ici
sans avoir de plan et juste en
espérant  pour trouver quelque chose quand ils arrivent
ici et je pense qu'il y a eu beaucoup
de gens vraiment heureux de trouver cette
communauté ici la seule chose qui craint,
c'est parfois que les salles de bain ne sont pas toujours
ouvertes, donc la salle de bain
parfois elles sont toutes prises tant de
gens  vivre ici, je ne pense pas que si j'avais
un petit ami, je les amènerais ici parce que
c'est ki  nd de comme vous n'avez pas beaucoup d'
intimité ici, donc si je le faisais, j'irais
certainement chez eux, je dirais que les
studios à LA sont comme 1 500 1
600 comme pour une seule chambre simple
donc cet endroit n'est que 750 par mois  donc
c'est vraiment abordable
[Musique]
savez-vous où vous laisseriez-vous
comment trouver ces trucs les futurs étaient
le spray le plus rapide Je ne pense pas que ce soit la
fin du rêve américain mais je pense que
c'est une nouvelle façon dont les gens sont
forcés  vivre pour suivre ce rêve
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la Chris DeRose Mon Cala phonies del Rey
de una palabra de selection agua para
compartir de salón a they say Arnold
Schwarzenegger génial University
technology removal combi Suleiman
Roseville California please  bienvenue à
l'étape 30 jours de Californie La
Californie est sans aucun doute le plus
bel endroit de ce pays nous sommes
les plus grands de la meilleure économie également de
ce pays cela ne veut pas dire que nous n'avons pas de
problèmes certains affectent nos sans-abris  s
problème est devenu une crise
[Musique]
nous avons dix villes dans chaque grande ville
de Californie Je veux dire regardez la crise
Grove conduisant mon vélo tous les matins à
travers Venise Je vois les tentes surgir
[Musique]
il y avait une femme par exemple sur le 60
un morceau de minutes qui était un facteur
pour le service postal américain qui vivait dans
sa voiture parce qu'elle ne pouvait pas payer son
appartement et j'ai été absolument choqué
quand j'ai vu que voir ce
travailleur postal sans abri à la télévision était un
rappel brutal un rappel brutal que le
le rêve d'être une classe moyenne en Amérique
s'éloigne lentement c'est une crise que
nous pouvons faire mieux et nous devons faire mieux
[Musique]
si dangereux - si un Pokémon applaudit, j'ai
dit Chris Rock California socket
Malhotra t8u jang youngsil i give dollar
vehicle
[  Rires]
[Musique]
Analia anaconda Jessie J a dirigé un berkeley
dans la prestigieuse université vp n was
washes l don't some continue il y a au
moins vingt huit adultes et environ quatre
enfants et c'est notre bi  g communauté
nous sommes des amis sur roues
ça va être chloé puis Pam puis
Janet puis nous avons Lucien de l'autre côté de la
rue puis nous avons la famille d'Ali de l'autre côté de
la rue derrière vous nous avons Nick alors
oui nous avons tous trouvé chez nous
ici dans ce  est la résection donc mon voisin
Frank lèvres ici non non mon
statut ici Frank est ici depuis environ
deux mois et elle est ici depuis cinq
ans de ce bloc qui est l'og
du bloc ouais je dors ici dans le
lit superposé et je  vous avez juste comme un
sac de couchage, vous savez parce que l'hiver a été le
plus froid, mais cela aide, cela aide vraiment,
c'est le canapé, il se transforme en
lit, alors j'en ai parfois, je peux
avoir une autre personne cherchant ici,
j'ai vécu dans ce camping-car  depuis l'
été 2017, il est assez courant de trouver des
étudiants sans-abri à l'UC Berkeley et
surtout parce que le marché du logement
est tellement cher que même le
logement étudiant de leur immeuble pour étudiants
n'est pas abordable.
vide parce qu'ils
demandent au moins deux mille dollars par mois
et c'est quelque chose que
nous n'avons pas tous en réalité pour qu'une personne
travaille à temps plein tout en allant à l'école à
plein temps aussi, vous savez que ce n'est pas facile
donc une chose  doit donner, mais oui, je
vois beaucoup d'étudiants abandonner ce
luxe du logement simplement parce qu'ils
veulent aller à l'école,
c'est l'itinérance dans les années 50 et 60, donc
vous savez si vous le regardez, beaucoup de
choses n'ont pas vraiment changé  vous savez que
vous avez encore des gens qui vivent dans la
rue vous savez que vous avez des familles vous
savez qui vivent dans de petits espaces c'est
fondamentalement ce qui se passe maintenant
rien à ce sujet n'a changé c'est
toujours pareil vous savez que rien n'a été vous
savez réparé donc j'ai juste l'impression que les gens
sont  être toujours mis dans ce genre de
situation vivant dans des refuges vous savez
au lieu de savoir chercher une
solution permanente et je pense que c'est ce que nous
devons faire vous savez que nous avons 50 ans à faire
ces solutions temporaires quand allons-nous
trouver un logement  tu sais ouais
je vis dans divers véhicules depuis
environ quatre ans et demi cinq ans je suis un
mécanicien mobile je connais des gens qui ont
deux emplois qui vivent encore dans une tente
sous un viaduc le coût de la
vie est absolument fou c'est tellement
cher de vivre ici
il n'y a plus de
rêve américain le rêve américain c'est de ne pas mourir endetté tu
sais c'est le rêve américain
obiagu magua capitaliste un accident la
mélodie de Livesey impact sur Oprah Zapata
cette importante Villa veux un gentil
productif ton éléphant n'était pas Pablo
Napoléon  de santé basalt avec un Zamora
stupide Staline kannada rekha jacking - Oh
Sheila McDowell
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Ella Fitness peut prendre une douche se nettoyer
parfois se raser J'ai décidé de laisser
ma bière cette fois et d'être comme une
personne normale  et fondamentalement, je me suis mis au travail à
partir d'ici et ouais c'est ma
routine quotidienne et je me sens comme une personne normale
comme si j'avais une maison et de cette façon personne ne
sait que je suis sans abri
[Musique]
quand je suis devenu sans abri le ve  ry
toute première nuit je me gare à l'extérieur d'un
restaurant que j'avais l'habitude d'aller tout le
temps je ne sais pas à quoi je pensais
peut-être en pensant qu'ils me défendraient
quelque chose s'est passé parce que j'étais juste
là c'était ma toute première nuit je
cherchais  pour les rues sombres ou les endroits où
je pourrais me garer et personne ne peut me voir à l'
intérieur de ma voiture là-bas ça doit aller
je garde à peu près dans ma voiture c'est mon
placard je garde ici les chaussures dont je pourrais avoir besoin
si je dois m'habiller pour le travail je  j'ai
trois emplois je fais de la comptabilité qui est la
comptabilité et je travaille dans une agence
immobilière je suis un acteur comme
n'importe qui vient ici après le
rêve hollywoodien ici à Los Angeles pour pouvoir
garder la vie que j'ai j'ai  pour gagner
probablement environ cinq mille dollars
chaque mois et certains mois j'en gagne à
peine deux mille maintenant je suis dans ma
chambre donc j'ai cette couverture Dieu merci
et puis ce que je fais je prends mon téléphone
je m'installe comme si j'étais dedans  le
cinéma, puis cherchez Netflix ces
à propos d'un gars qui possède à peu près la ville
et puis je me couvre juste et
ensuite je vais dormir c'est à peu près
ce que je fais tous les soirs
[Musique]
ils disent toujours que c'est le meilleur pays
du monde mais les gens qui peuvent travailler
pourquoi faire  tu dois être dans la rue
ce qui ne va pas avec ce pays
[Musique]